this is a teacher if you would believe
it a bunch of middle schoolers owned
this woke teacher when she asked for
their pronouns it's from libs of tick
tock let's see what the teacher says
though even just ignore the caption and
think for yourself and think about how
you feel about this
okay to talk i really need your help
here on this one i'm a teacher i teach
fifth in sixth grade and uh this morning
i don't know somehow um the concept of
pronouns came up um and
one of my students said well miss o'dell
did you even ask me my pronouns and i
was like whoa
i hadn't actually asked him his pronouns
and i had called him a hymn and i
i said oh i'm so sorry i haven't
actually called you i mean asked you
what your pronouns are and
what are they he said
i'm sorry banana said banana and rock
and i was like dude no like
don't mess around i was i was actually
really upset because
i thought he was making fun of it and in
fact i'm still pretty sure he was making
fun of it and um but they all agreed no
like you can choose anything banana rock
if you want banana and rock to be a
pronoun banana watch your pronoun
is it tick-tock tell me
okay
this woman teaches in in classrooms
this is a grown ass woman and she's
legitimately asking you like
well if they say rock and banana like do
what like
tell me like do i have to acknowledge
that
this is where we're at do you understand
what's going on
these kids are having a field day with
this first of all they're like oh
pronouns i'm rock i'm foam
i'm pen i'm water
and they're like you have to you have to
play
that because they they can't for the
life of them some of them probably
figure out what's going on here they're
young their minds cannot wrap around
someone comes in and it's like i'm a
girl today i'm a boy tomorrow like
they're like oh you can just be whatever
you want to be
wouldn't that be a logical endpoint for
a child's mind fifth grader on this
yes
yes it would they'd be like oh today i'm
gonna let's it's like dress up right
it's like a it's like you play house
today i'm gonna be the mom today i'm
gonna be the dad today i'm gonna be the
cat
you know this is what's happening and
the teacher
these people are i don't know some type
of dysfunction is going on here first of
all what are you going on to you're a
grown woman what are you doing on tick
tock asking somebody
you don't know
in the classroom that the student can't
just say that they're a rock
you can't well no you know why
because if she looks the little boy and
says you can't call yourself a rock
today how in the same breath is she
going to look at that little boy and say
you can't call yourself a girl today
because it's not a girl it's a little
boy
do you understand what what happens here
now you're going to have a whole bunch
of adults in settings that don't know
how to behave
because in a world where facts cease to
exist and everything is subjective
everything is subjective
everything
so they're not going to be able to scold
you like they don't
so now they've got to go to tick-tock
and be like help me what do i do and you
know what a lot of kooks are going to
say well let him be a rock
let him be maybe he feels like a banana
that day
can you imagine
adults out there can you imagine being a
child growing up in this conf absolute
confusion all the time
i mean it's two and two four
what if it's not four to me i'm bad at
math
i am let's not forget that is racist
two and two doesn't equal four two two
and two is five and to say two and two
equals four is racist well that's
misogynistic that's right because the
entire because patriarchy
because patriarchy
because the entire structure that we
operate in
is racist and misogynist so two and two
equals four was created in that
structure so i'm making a five i feel
better and now we all gotta say no
really though where is this going
where is it going
you're not worried about even if you're
like okay this doesn't directly affect
my life it's going to it is going to
affect your life in some way this is
absolute madness and nobody can say it
because everyone's afraid that the
second they say that they're going to
get canceled so i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
going to say it this is madness
this is way beyond way beyond the live
and let live now
you got kids in class that are going to
be able to say
yeah what about halloween
what if they want to make halloween
every day i dressed up as madonna many
times like a virgin had my outfit i'm
madonna
i'm madonna what if i came in here and i
was like i'm madonna if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]